[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Hello.
Welcome to "Spend Less Time
Diagnosing and More Time
Developing."
I'm Erik McClenney, a
software engineer at Google
on developer infrastructure.
SHARAT SHROFF: And
I'm Sharat Shroff.
I'm a product manager working
on developer infrastructure.
And our goal is to make
developers' lives easier.
I know you're all here to
learn about the various tools
and diagnostic tools that
we're about to show you.
But first we should
probably talk about the app.
Right?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Yeah.
SHARAT SHROFF: So the
app that we have built
is basically a meme generator.
So you can take any
two bodies of text
and throw it at this app.
This app will basically
take randomly picked words
from these bodies of text,
kind of mush them together
in some logical manner to
hopefully sometimes create
a funny meme.
So for this demo, we decided to
take-- the two bodies of text
that we decided to
use is "Grimms' Fairy
Tales" and, of course,
everyone's favorite bedtime
reading, the "Git Handbook."
So let's walk
through what happens
when you try this app out.
Here's a good example.
It says, "The wolf and the wild
boar were first on the ground;
and when they came,
he gave them some
of the most annoying
problems known
to humanity: version-controlling
Microsoft Word documents."
And that's pretty--
that's pretty rough.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: I
don't know if that's
the most annoying problem.
Maybe one of them.
SHARAT SHROFF: So you want
to just walk them through
on how it works?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Sure.
What we're doing is we're
taking fragments from each
of the source sentences.
And you can see, we kind
of have a little fancy font
for the "Grimms' Fairy Tales."
And we have kind
of a nice monospace
font for the "Git Handbook."
And for each of the
source fragments,
we've highlighted them
in the source sentence,
and then we've kind of chained
them together, as you see here.
SHARAT SHROFF: Yeah.
And sometimes, you can see,
it's taken about eight sentences
to make this.
We've taken words
randomly across eight
different sentences,
assembled all of this.
This is all happening
in a state machine
that's running on App Engine.
And I've seen this app
sometimes take 12, 13 sentences,
sometimesas few as
three sentences.
You can start sometimes
in "Git Handbook"
and go to "Grimms'," and
sometimes you can start from
"Grimms'" to "Git" and "Grimms'"
and so on, any combination.
You know, let's skip
this another example
and tell you how the
app itself is built.
It's a very straightforward,
very simple app.
Your two bodies of text
that I was talking about
exist in GCS in two
different stores.
We have a run time.
It's basically a Java app
which has a state machine.
And of course, the green
box indicates the client.
Why don't we just
show them the app?
ERIK MCCLENNEY:
That's a good idea.
Here's the app running.
As you can see, I have
another sentence here.
"He went to the fireplace
to make a comment on it,
GitHub notices that and
collapses the outdated diff."
SHARAT SHROFF: It's
[INAUDIBLE], I guess.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Is that funny?
I don't know.
There's another feature
we haven't talked about,
which is our voting feature.
So we can click one of
these buttons down here,
and it will record our
response and then generate
another sentence.
I don't know.
I think it's a little funny,
so I'll click that one.
SHARAT SHROFF: Did
you click on it?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: I did.
It's sitting--
it's loading here.
SHARAT SHROFF: Wow.
That's taking a
really long time.
You don't expect us to
ship this app, do you?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Uh-- well.
SHARAT SHROFF: That--
ERIK MCCLENNEY: It's a
demo app so we're probably
never going to ship it.
But I mean, if we
were to ship this,
I think we'd want to investigate
this little performance
problem here.
SHARAT SHROFF: Yeah, so what do
you think we're going to use?
ERIK MCCLENNEY:
Well, a good option
to use for these kinds
of things is logs.
Logs are very--
they're very flexible.
We can record any
information that we want.
In the case of App
Engine, they tell us
how long our requests take.
We could start there.
SHARAT SHROFF: Use Trace, maybe?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: We also
have a Trace product.
And it's convenient
because I happen
to have worked on this product.
SHARAT SHROFF: Of course.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: It's designed
to show us [INAUDIBLE]
information for our
apps and kind of give us
a view into the service
RPCs that our apps call.
SHARAT SHROFF: So while
you're pulling up the app,
why don't I just-- could you
just go back to the slides?
I could just talk about-- so
when we think about performance
troubleshooting and
production, we've
heard engineers tell
that, of course,
you need to be able to
very accurately and very
precisely measure
requests, measure latency
at an individual request level.
You also need to be able to
correlate logs so that you
actually get this
entire view of what's
happening within
your application
from a latency point of view.
And you need to be able to
look at different distribution
slices.
And what I mean by
that is, average
itself doesn't tell you much.
You need to be able to look
at the 75th percentile.
When you look at
an average view,
an average aggregate view,
of the latency associated
with your application, you
may not notice any issues.
But if you slice it down
to the 75th percentile
or the 95th percentile, you'll
start seeing those differences
in latencies, and that
becomes a place where
you want to start diving into.
And the other thing that we
have heard customers often say
is, performance is something
that people end up-- engineers
end up reacting to while they
would much rather prefer being
proactive about this, to
be aware of the problems
even before it actually
impacts the customers.
So with all that in
mind, we ended up
building Stackdriver Trace.
And for Stackdriver Trace, we
started off with, of course,
providing this very-- we
automatically trace every end
point that you have.
And we are able to surface that
within the Stackdriver Trace
tool.
We also overlaid this log.
So we can basically--
in this diagram what
you see here is,
basically, we tell you
what's happening across
here the entire time taken
for your entire request.
And then we also break it down
into its constituent parts
and tell you where exactly
the time is being spent.
We are able to also break
down by different distribution
slices.
So you can actually
tell, for example,
what is your application
latency of the 25th percentile,
at the 75th or the
50th percentile.
And we're also able to tell
you whether it's actually
going up or down.
Erik will show you some
of these in a second.
And we have spent
a bunch of time
looking at being able to provide
analysis on all of these.
And Erik, I think we should just
actually show them the tool.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: All right.
Maybe you could
drive here while I--
SHARAT SHROFF: Yeah,
actually, why don't I do that?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Here we have
our Trace Overview page.
And the page is
organized in a number
of cards that are
designed to give
different views into the trace
data that we have for the app.
On the upper right side,
we have our Insights card.
And this shows some
of the insights
that Sharat just talked about.
And we'll look at
this in more detail.
We see one that's called
many datastore.next calls.
Maybe that will come up
later in our conversation.
And then below that,
we have a few lists
of traces that are
organized on different ways.
The first one, the traces
are organized by recency.
And then below
that, we have traces
organized both by
frequency of request URL
and by frequency of
App Engine service RPC.
On the right side, we have
our list of analysis reports.
This is what we were
showing just a moment ago
in the slides.
The analysis reports are
capable of running over
large numbers of traces.
And they can show you
a latency histogram
for your app for the
requests that it handles.
And what we do on
the daily reports.
These ones are
generated automatically.
And if we have enough data,
we can show two reports.
In this case, for
the daily reports
we have the first day,
which is yesterday.
And then we have a
week before yesterday.
And we're kind of showing you
those two reports side by side.
So this can show you if you
have a latency shift, perhaps,
in your app.
SHARAT SHROFF: It's
probably also worth
noting that this report, this
comparison between reports,
need not be just
done on a time basis.
You can do it on a
version-to-version basis.
So we can generate
reports saying,
tell me my application
profile and compare it
with what it was with
my previous version.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: That's right.
And for the daily reports, the
ones that are automatically
generated, we
choose from requests
that were sent to the
most frequent URIs.
That's another place that
we use that information.
All right.
Well, when we try to
generate our sentence,
that took a little longer
than we thought it should.
So now we're going to look at a
trace detail for the sentence.
So we can see here, we've got
some long-running requests here
for sentence.
That one took almost 19 seconds.
We're going to look at the
Trace Detail page for this.
SHARAT SHROFF: Should
I click on that?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Yes, you should.
SHARAT SHROFF: OK.
Should we start
using Trace on our--
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Maybe we should
use Trace to diagnose this?
SHARAT SHROFF: Should use our
own feature on our service?
Is that what you're saying?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: I'm
not saying that.
You're saying that.
But it's a good idea.
But actually, there's
something going on here,
and we'll talk about that, too.
SHARAT SHROFF: Or
is it just trying
to retrieve a whole
bunch of data?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: It's trying
to retrieve a lot of data.
So here we see our trace.
Now a trace is a bucket--
basically, a group of spins.
And the spins have
some basic information.
They have a name.
And then we get the latency
information by the timing
that we have in the spins.
There's both a start
time and an end time.
So we can organize
spins kind of in space.
And we also have the
latency for them.
And they also have a hierarchy.
So the request here, the
entire request duration,
we see in the first spin,
called slash sentence.
And then all the
ones below that are
children of that parent spin.
So it gives us a
hierarchical representation
of what our app is doing.
SHARAT SHROFF: There's
a huge number of these.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: There is
a large number of those.
And I think probably the page
load was because we're actually
loading probably
thousands of these things
and showing them
here in our browser.
So in fact, there's so
many, I mean, you barely
see that little
scroll thumb moving.
I can't even count these.
So why don't we click on
the Summary tab there?
SHARAT SHROFF: OK.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Now
on the Summary tab,
it shows us by request
and service RPC
just how many of these
spins that we see.
In this case, we see over
2,000 datastore.next calls.
Below that we see that we
have eight run query calls.
And I think, with
this information,
I have kind of an idea
of what our app is doing.
And let me just go back
to the Grimm Git app
here for just a second.
We don't need to show it.
I'm just going to
explain what it's doing.
What it does to generate that
list of source sentences is,
you've got a large state machine
with all the different sentence
fragments in it.
And we just kind of
walk that to generate
the generated sentence.
But to come up with the source
sentences for each source that
was chosen for the node
for that sentence fragment,
we hash the sentence.
And we store that
hash in the node.
We do this because we
have a lot of sentences
and a lot of nodes.
And we don't want to replicate
all the sentences everywhere.
And then we look
into our data store
by hash to find each of
the source sentences.
So in this case, we
had a sentence that
had eight source sentences.
And we did eight queries.
But for some reason, that
turned into over 2,000
datastore.next calls.
SHARAT SHROFF: Wow.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: And this is
one of the benefits of Trace.
It kind of gives us this view.
If you look at the
code, we don't actually
see ourselves ever
calling datastore.next.
But we're going to use
Trace to figure out
why that's happening.
Now we click on
the Insights tab,
and you can see it's telling us
there's one insight on the tab.
If you click on
it, and actually we
see the insight that we
saw on the Insight card.
And it says, many
datastore.next calls.
And it's warning
us that, not only
do we have a lot of these calls
and it has the correct number,
but it's telling us
that we have a default.
Maybe we have a batch
size for our query of 20.
And I know that 20 is
the default batch size.
And this is probably why we have
so many of these next calls.
Now one thing that I think
is notable is, in this case,
we kind of have to
diagnose our problem.
We started at the Overview page.
We clicked on the actual
summary, the sentence link,
from our list of traces.
We went to the Detail page.
We looked off the summary to
see how many of these calls
we made.
We ended up at Insights.
We could have just
clicked on Insights
from that Overview
page and skipped
some of the investigation.
So this is kind of one of the
values of our Insights feature.
SHARAT SHROFF: The
other thing to remember
is what we are showing here
is just one such pattern.
We are analyzing
every single trace
that comes into our
system, every one of them.
We analyze for
numerous patterns.
When we see a suboptimal
pattern in your call flow,
we immediately surface it out.
So you have these
insights available to you
the moment you land
on the Trace page.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: And we're
working on new insights
all the time.
SHARAT SHROFF: We're always
working on new insights, yeah.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: So now
we're going to go back
to our timeline here.
And we're going to go to
that section of code that
has that problem.
So to do this, we're going to
click on one of the first run
query there.
SHARAT SHROFF: OK.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Now I
mentioned that each spin
has some basic information.
It's got a name.
It's got some
timing information.
You scroll down, we also
see we have some of what
we call annotations or labels.
These can be used
to actually add
extra custom data to the spins.
And for App Engine spins we add
a number of different things
based on the service
API we called.
So you can see for datastore
we have kind of like the batch
size in there.
In fact, it says 20 right there.
We have the kind, which
just roughly corresponds
to the table that the data
came from for that request.
Below that, we also
have a call stack.
And this is going to help us
kind of find the place in code
where we have our bug
or performance problem.
And you can see, in our call
stack we have many frames.
They're frames that are kind of
part of the SDK, the App Engine
SDK.
We have some App
Engine infrastructure,
some servlet container code.
But we have some links
here for the frames
that correspond to our app.
SHARAT SHROFF: They
just shipped this.
You're going a little bit
off script, you realize that.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: I know.
I actually--
SHARAT SHROFF: They shipped
it in the last 20 minutes,
I think, or last half an hour.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: I know.
I was hoping that
nobody would modify this
while we're doing the demo.
SHARAT SHROFF: Do
you click on it?
ERIK MCCLENNEY:
These things happen.
Let's click on that.
SHARAT SHROFF: Which one?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Click
on the first one.
SHARAT SHROFF: All right.
It should take it to
the Debugger here?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Yeah, it will.
And we'll-- this is a little
sneak peek of-- sorry,
to give you another peek on it.
SHARAT SHROFF: The team
is just shipping stuff
as we are demoing here.
So we didn't expect
to see those links.
Those links were not
supposed to be there.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Actually,
they are supposed to be here.
Just--
SHARAT SHROFF: But not today.
Not right now.
But nevertheless.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: OK.
So here we have our Debugger.
And we have source code located.
We've uploaded our source code
here into the Google Cloud
Source Repository.
That's why we have
that available.
And we're actually to talk about
this Debugger in a few minutes.
But what this is
doing is it's letting
me take a look at the code that
I have for my find sentence
method.
This is the method that
goes through the datastore.
As I mentioned, it kind
of looks for sentences
with a matching hash.
And let's look at what it does.
It first sets up a
query, and then it
goes through all
the entities it gets
from the iterator from
that iterable there.
And for each entity, it
looks at the value property.
The value property is the
source sentence itself.
And then we hash the sentence.
And then we compare the
hashes for equality.
The hash that we
pass into the method
is the one that we got
out of our state machine.
And it's curious to me because
I remember working on this.
And I know that when I write
the entities into the datastore,
I actually write a
hash property there.
So right away you can
see, we're computing
a hash for the sentence
from the datastore.
But that's not the only thing.
By adding the hash
property, by default
the datastore gives
us a secondary index
on that property.
So I can actually apply a filter
to my query and do a lookup.
What this is doing by iterating
through the table this way,
we're actually potentially
iterating over all the entities
in the table for this kind.
And we know the hash already
for what we're looking for.
So we should be able
to just do a lookup.
Now as I mentioned, by default
you don't see anything here
about batch size.
The default batch size is 20.
And what the SDK code is doing
is it's saying, all right,
we're going to query this
table for these entities.
And it's fetching ahead the
batch size number of entities.
And it's holding those there
as we iterate through them.
And when we exhaust that, it
goes and gets the next batch.
So you've got to have
some default batch size.
And 20 is probably good
for some common use cases,
like maybe a web page
or the tabular view.
SHARAT SHROFF: Yeah.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Right?
In this case, we know
that we're iterating
through the entire table.
So 20 is probably
too small, given
that we have thousands of
sentences in this table.
So what I'm going
to do is replace
where we call this with a
call to another method that
applies a filter.
And having planned
ahead, I actually
have such a method down below.
Maybe you could scroll down
a little bit past all these
to-- keep going, keep going.
Don't be shy.
Keep going.
All right, right there.
Find sentence with filter.
This one adds a
filter to our query
and adds a predicate with
an equality operator.
So we're looking for
entities with the property
hash that equals the
hash that we pass in.
And they should translate into
a datastore lookup instead
of a scan.
You won't be scanning
through the whole table.
Chunks of 20 sentences
at a time here.
We'll go straight
to our sentence.
SHARAT SHROFF:
Should we try it out?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: So why
don't we try this out?
SHARAT SHROFF: Yeah.
So the unscripted part
here, as you folks realized,
we clicked on a feature
that probably just got
enabled some point today.
You have the ability to
jump from Stackdriver Trace
into Debugger.
We'll talk a little more about
Debugger in just a few minutes.
In the meantime--
ERIK MCCLENNEY: So I built,
and I'm building and deploying
this thing.
And I'm going to
just go and change it
back to the slides so you can--
SHARAT SHROFF: Yeah.
So why don't we go
back to the slides,
and I can talk a little bit?
Where's the clicker?
There it is.
So the thing to remember
about Trace is it's always on.
It's ready.
It's available out of the
box for all App Engine
applications.
We do all the joining and
aggregation in the back end.
All the reports that you see,
we generate a lot of them
automatically.
And if you want to
generate more and you
want to generate your own custom
reports for a specific end
point or over a specific time
period, specific version,
you can do all of that.
We are checking for
regression all the time
in the sense that
we are checking
for latency regressions
or performance
regressions from one version
to another over time.
And we surface that
to you as well.
And the recruiting team.
You'll see this in
the remaining tools.
There is minuscule overhead.
There's very little overhead
for your application.
Think in terms of single-digit
milliseconds or lesser,
in the order of
microseconds, that we
do when we do sample a request
and take a trace for it.
Oh, the clicker isn't working.
Ah.
I'll just quickly
go through how Trace
works at a very high level.
What we have here in that
box is-- yeah, right there.
Well, this is basically the
app that we're talking about.
It sits on top of the
App Engine platform.
And what Trace does is it
hooks into the request handling
there so that every time you
may do a URL fetch or an RPC,
we are able to do
the start and stop.
And we send out the
logs, and from there it
gets shipped to
our trace service.
Gets shipped back
to a back end store.
We had to do some map reviews.
And Erik and his team
do some magic there,
and we have this
analysis and report
that we just talked about.
We also have Trace API that
you can use to extend it
so that, if you have your
own internal workflows,
as an example, that
you want to trace,
and you want to overlay
it on the trace data,
and you want to leverage all the
goodness that we talked about,
you can use it by using
the API and an SDK
that we have out there.
We also have the ability to
use the same APIs to show
trace data into your own tools.
So are we ready to
go try this out?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Yeah, we are.
SHARAT SHROFF: All right.
Let's do it.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: So here
we have another sentence
that we generated last time.
And I don't even know
how to read that.
"README 12 plus plus
1 file changed."
SHARAT SHROFF:
Yeah, this doesn't--
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Maybe
this isn't that funny.
We'll click that.
SHARAT SHROFF:
Doesn't make sense.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: But you
can see we've greatly
improved the performance
of our app here.
SHARAT SHROFF: That
is much better.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: It's faster.
In fact, if we were to
look here at the trace.
Let's see, look at
a trace list here.
You can see here, this slash
sentence took 220 milliseconds.
Now this is-- you can see what
I was talking about before.
Down here it says, we have
four source sentences.
Actually, this must not
correspond to the same one.
But we have just a number
of run query calls here,
and we have no
datastore.next calls.
So this is the reason why
our app is so much faster.
SHARAT SHROFF: This
looks much better.
I mean, the app is shipworthy.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Why don't
you give it a whirl?
SHARAT SHROFF: I mean,
I think right now
we're probably ready to try out
a different set of source text
data.
This is really good.
It's great.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: What did it--
SHARAT SHROFF: Whoa!
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Whoa!
That's a lot of red there.
500 internal server error.
SHARAT SHROFF: If I had to
channel my inner Yoda to you--
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Oh, no.
SHARAT SHROFF: Introduced
a bug you have.
I mean, this looks
like a pretty bad bug.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Maybe
not as bad as the joke,
but-- no, I'm just kidding.
That was a good joke.
That was good.
Your Yoda-- with a little
more work, your Yoda
is going to be this top flight.
SHARAT SHROFF: So what
are we going to do?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: We're
going to-- well,
like I said before, logs is kind
of the theme that we have here.
Logs are a great tool.
They're very flexible.
We can probably find
the place in code
where this is happening.
And we can look
and see if there's
anything in there, maybe
an exception or something.
SHARAT SHROFF: That's like going
through, I don't know, like,
you know, tons and tons of logs.
ERIK MCCLENNEY:
Probably a lot of logs.
SHARAT SHROFF: Stackdriver
Error Reporting?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Yes,
that's why we're here.
We'll talk about
error reporting.
SHARAT SHROFF: Right.
So let's talk about
error reporting.
So as Erik was just describing,
I mean, we could certainly
go look at logs.
You've got errors scattered
everywhere, all over logs.
And it's really difficult
to get this overall view.
It's also difficult to evaluate
the impact of just looking
at errors within the logs.
So great.
If you do find an error
in a log, what do you do?
Do you basically stop everything
and start trying to fix it?
I mean, what is the best way to
gauge when you encounter errors
in the log?
It's always been
a difficult thing.
Discovering new issues
takes a long time.
Very often you get to
know about issues only
after your customers
have already seen it
and start complaining.
And it's difficult
to validate often
whether the fixes that you
have made in the version
that you're about to ship out
have actually solved the error
or not.
And I mean, if
anyone is-- I'm sure
everyone here has probably
looked at error log statement.
And there's just so
much noise in there.
There is so much stuff in
there, irrelevant, very often
irrelevant stuff, that, I guess,
my eyes tend to glaze over.
So what we did is,
this morning we
launched publicly
Stackdriver Error Reporting.
If there's one takeaway I
want everyone to have here is,
if there's a page that you
want to pin to your favorites,
it's probably Error Reporting.
I'll just walk through the
various parts really quickly,
and then we can just start
looking at the tool itself.
There's a lot of
information, and our goal
is to give you at-a-glance view
of all the errors happening
within your application.
We go about taking
all the errors
that encounter across all the
instances across all the logs--
logs across all instances.
And we group them
intelligently so
that you don't have to worry
about how often it's occurring.
We allow you to slice it
by different time periods.
You can slice it by
different versions.
We have an easy way to show
that a new error has occurred,
a very intuitive way
to immediately spot
when a new error has occurred.
We try to tell you,
when available,
the customer impact, how many
customers are being impacted.
You can sign up
for notifications.
And you can link it to your
own backtracking system.
So all of this goes-- there
is a tremendous amount
of information here.
But I think, why don't we just
actually see it in action?
Oh, actually, before we do that.
Let me just--
ERIK MCCLENNEY: See,
there's an action first.
SHARAT SHROFF: So
this is, again,
a very high-level view of
how Error Reporting works.
In just a ton of logs,
there's a big black box,
or blue box in this case, which
does a bunch of processing
and grouping.
And we basically--
output of that
is this intelligent
grouping that we'll
see in action in a few minutes.
That, of course, goes to
a service, which allows
us to do a bunch of things.
And as well as surface this
to our UI using an API.
And that API, just like on the
trace, is available for you
to ingest into your
own third-party tools.
And of course, we
have a notifier
that sends you notification
when there's a new error.
Should we look at the tool?
ERIK MCCLENNEY:
Yeah, let's do that.
And one thing I want to mention.
All these can be found here
on the left, down here, where
it says Stackdriver.
You've got Debug, which
we showed you briefly
a second ago.
You've got Trace and
Error Reporting, which
we're talking about today.
Logging, which
we're not bashing.
Logging is great, but I'm
going to keep bringing this up.
And we've got Monitoring under
the Stackdriver section there.
And you can also
pin these things.
SHARAT SHROFF: Exactly.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Is that
what you were going to say?
SHARAT SHROFF: That's exactly
what I was about to say.
ERIK MCCLENNEY:
We practiced this.
This is why we're-- but on the
top I've got my Error Reporting
icon.
So I'm going to click that one.
And here we have
our Overview page.
And we showed you
this briefly before.
And here we have our errors that
are kind of organized by kind.
And off to the right,
we have one that
happened three minutes ago.
And I think this-- just
going to go on a limb
and say this is probably the
one that we want to click.
This probably is
what we saw before.
It's also telling us
that the status that it's
seeing for these is 500, which
matches the big sea of red
that you saw before.
So we're going to click this.
And we're looking at
the error details.
At the top of the page here,
the top table that we've got,
we see some of the
same information
that we saw in the Overview page
that corresponds to this error.
We have a blown-up histogram.
As you go through this,
you'll see the frequency
that we've had over time
for this error type.
And then for each type of error,
we have a number of samples.
And for each sample, we have
some additional information.
And this kind of is
information about the request
or the environment that
the app is running in.
And this is designed to help
us reproduce this problem.
We can see we've got
the full request URL.
We've got the status,
which we saw firsthand.
Then we've got some headers.
We've got the user
agent with refer.
And App Engine
information, this default
is the App Engine module.
And then we have the version
that the app was running
when it handled this request.
Now below this, we
have a stack trace.
But this stack trace looks
different from the one
that we saw in cloud trace,
in Stackdriver Trace.
Why is that?
SHARAT SHROFF: It's cleaner.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: It is cleaner.
SHARAT SHROFF: It's much better.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: It's a
lot different to my eyes.
Well, if I expand this, you'll
see what's happened here.
As I said before, in our stack
trace we have many frames.
A lot of them are kind
of infrastructure.
It doesn't mean that
the bug we're seeing
doesn't happen there,
but it's probably
more likely that it's happening
in our application code,
for us to be honest
with ourselves.
So here we've kind
of formatted this.
And we've grayed out the kind
of infrastructure frames.
And then we just show
it with the ability
to collapse it so that we just
see our frames from our app.
So this is very
useful in helping
us kind of just visually see
where our errors are happening.
SHARAT SHROFF:
That's exactly what
I was talking about
where, if you just
show the raw information
there, I mean, it's
difficult to discern.
And I think that's really
cool that you can actually
zero in on exactly
where the problem is.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Yeah.
And now looking
at this, I think I
have an idea of where
this bug is happening.
SHARAT SHROFF: Oh, yeah?
Where is it?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Apparently,
it's on [INAUDIBLE] servlet,
that class, a method
called doGet line 122.
SHARAT SHROFF: I mean, how
are you going to confirm that?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Well, one
option would be to use logs.
I said I was going
to say this again.
And of course, we
could go in there
and we can instrument
our code some more.
We can try to guess it.
This is a null
pointer exception,
so we can see if we're
dereferencing something that
looks like it might be null.
And we can print the logs out.
We can build.
We can redeploy.
We can hit the app again.
It's a lot of fun.
SHARAT SHROFF: So that
involves you writing logs, then
building and deploying, and
then again getting the logs,
reviewing them.
And so we're going to keep
doing this for every bug?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Just
this one to start with.
But wouldn't it be great
if we had a tool, though,
where we could see this
happening while it's running?
SHARAT SHROFF: And
on cue we're going
to talk about Cloud Debugger.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Debugger.
Excellent.
And I said this was
going to come up again.
SHARAT SHROFF: We could
talk about Debugger.
I mean, I could go
through more slides.
But why don't we just show
them the tool in action?
ERIK MCCLENNEY: OK, that's good.
SHARAT SHROFF: And I could
try to cover the slides later.
ERIK MCCLENNEY:
That's a good idea.
Now here again we
have another link.
And this will take us
to what we saw before.
And this time we'll stay in
Debugger for a little longer.
Now what's happening
here, we see
our source that's loaded here.
And just to let you
know, the Debugger
has different options for
getting access to source code.
In this case, we're using
our Cloud Source Repository.
We've got the source
code loaded here.
So it knows by kind
of module and version
and, by the deployment,
what's running here.
It can also read code
from local source.
In this case, it doesn't
actually send any of the source
to Google at all.
It just loads the source
in the browser session
and gets the
information it needs
to set these snapshots here.
In fact, I think we can
even do that without any--
SHARAT SHROFF: Yeah.
I mean, let's assume that, if
you don't have access to source
code at all, you
can just give it
a filename and a line
number, and it'll still
take a snapshot.
And when you take a snapshot,
as we did, what I was doing here
is I was just reproing the
same error on my laptop here,
and we got a snapshot.
This is happening in production.
It is not impacting
any of the users.
So we are basically-- we're
adding minimal overhead
to your application.
Again, we're thinking about
single-digit milliseconds
or microseconds.
It doesn't even matter
whether your application
is running on one instance
or 100,000 instances.
We will still be able
to capture a snapshot
and capture the entire
application state,
no matter which instance it
is, and then bring it back.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Yeah,
and that's important.
When we think about
debuggers, we often
think about setting a
breakpoint and then halting
execution of the code and maybe
playing around with the machine
state, setting registers,
backing up the code pointer,
running it again.
And that's great
in some situations
when we have a dedicated
machine where we
can reproduce these problems.
Often with cloud apps, we don't
have that kind of flexibility.
Some of the problems
that we see may
be due to maybe resource
limitations or lots of user
traffic.
We may not easily be able to
reproduce these problems when
they happen in
distributed apps this way.
So what a snapshot
will let us do
is capture a view of the machine
state on whatever machine
that the snapshot's taken from.
And it'll save it away
in a session for us
to look at any time.
And it won't interfere
with the operation,
as we just mentioned.
So as Sharat said, while
we were doing that,
he actually hit the app again.
I see a big red box there.
And we took the snapshot.
You may have noticed it
said, waiting for snapshot.
And we executed this code.
So now I'm going to
rearrange the screen
a little bit so we can get a
little better view on this.
Well, I guess that's
as low as that goes.
This one.
There you go.
Should be able to do that.
OK.
Well, I'll just scroll
through these guys.
As we can see, we've got
local variables here.
You can see you've got--
this is an instance method.
So we have a This pointer.
And then we have our request
and response parameters there.
They're passed in.
Then we have some local
variables down here.
We have vote LOL because
we pressed the LOL button
to make this thing explode.
We have current null.
It's probably what we're
interested in here.
So we're going to take
a look at the code
and see what we're doing.
Now, thinking back on this,
I remember what I did.
I think, as we improve upon
this sentence generator,
we're going to keep track of
the quality of the sentences
that it produces.
So we have these voting
buttons, and eventually we're
going to probably store
these in some kind of system
where we can run some
analytics on them.
We can record information
maybe about how long
it took a user before
they clicked a button
and which options they
chose for which sentences.
But for now, since I was asked
to do this in short notice,
I just take them and
stick them into a map,
just to have something, just
to get some code out the door.
So it looks like I am taking
out of my vote counts map.
I'm retrieving a vote
with key vote there.
And then taking the
current integer,
a box integer that we have.
I'm adding 1 to it, and I'm
running it back into our map.
I can see right away if
vote is not in the map,
then the current will be null.
And why is vote not in the map?
I clicked the LOL button.
And I'm going to look up here
where I initialize my map.
And I can see someone, maybe
me, got a little excited here,
and I put LOL in caps.
And when I look at
what we have here,
you see that lol is lowercase.
Now this is terrible code.
It's not robust.
We should never do
anything like this ever.
But we did, and we
suffered the consequences.
But Debugger helped
us find the problem.
SHARAT SHROFF: So that's right.
I mean, the way
Stackdriver Debugger
works, it just completely
revolutionizes, in my opinion,
how you would debug
code in production.
You can capture
application state,
study your behavior of
your code, and all of this
without ever having to pause,
interrupt your application.
And all of this data is
available in near real time.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: We also have the
ability to share this session.
SHARAT SHROFF: Ah, that's right.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: I don't have
anyone to share it with,
but I can share it with myself.
So I'll just copy
the link here, and I
will put this into a new
tab that will run this.
You can see we've got
the same session run.
We have our snapshot
there in the same line,
in the same file.
And we've got the same
state, the same stack trace,
the same-- ah, there we go.
This is what I was
trying to do before.
And the same variables.
SHARAT SHROFF: That's right.
I mean, the ability for you to
share your debugging sessions
or any of your
diagnosis sessions
across any of these tools is
as easy as a copy and a paste.
And if the person receiving it
has access to those resources,
they'll just be able to
see the exact same data.
And in this case, you can see
the entire-- all the variables.
You can see the stack.
You can see everything.
So it makes it really
easy for engineers
to collaborate,
which often happens,
in order to
troubleshoot your app.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: That's right.
SHARAT SHROFF: All right.
So it looks like you
can fix that bug later.
Should we just go
back to the slides?
So I actually went
through all of these.
I think we went
So I think the slides are
a little bit redundant.
And I think I'm just going to
go to-- this is again redundant.
I think the only thing
I'll call out here
is, we have many
source code options.
I think Erik talked about it.
We've got local and cloud repo.
And you can upload your code.
And when you do
upload your code,
that code is stored by GCP.
And it's available for the
entire debugging session.
So when you do a share,
you close your browser,
come back later,
and somebody else--
or you share it
with somebody else,
that code is available for you.
You can do with
no source at all.
Just give a filename and a
line number and that's it.
Again, a very-- it's
like a [INAUDIBLE] view
of how Debugger works.
We've got a debugger service,
we've got debugger agents.
And we've got an
agent controller.
When you set up a snapshot,
your debugger service
coordinates with the debugger
agent, takes a snapshot,
sends it back, and you basically
see what we just demoed.
So just to summarize.
When you're diagnosing
an application,
hopefully it's pretty
clear for everyone
that, if you're dealing
with performance issues,
Trace should be one of
the first destinations
to understand what is happening
within your application
and to be able to slice and
dice the Trace data so that you
can actually find the root
cause and find the bottlenecks.
Error Reporting, as
I've emphasized, pin it.
If you've got an
application running in GCP,
go ahead and pin the
Error Reporting page.
And that's something
that is going
to be tremendously useful.
Our customers, whom we
have already released it to
on a private beta,
have come back
with phenomenal feedback telling
us how incredibly valuable
it is.
And Debug, I think this is one
of those things where-- it's
one of the best tools that
I've used, personally,
in terms of stepping through
the behavior of your code
and understanding
what is happening
within your application
without really interrupting
your normal operations.
As I've already talked about
before, all of this stuff
works natively in a
distributed environment.
We can scale very comfortably.
We can scale from one
instance, if your application's
running in one instance to--
many of our customers run
their application in hundreds
of thousands of instances.
And so we can capture
all this data seamlessly.
Another aspect of scale to
think about is, say, take Trace,
for example.
We have about a billion traces,
approximately a billion traces,
coming into our
system every day.
And every one of those
traces is analyzed
to look for different call
patterns, suboptimal call
patterns.
Then we surface that.
This is tightly integrated
into developer workflows.
And of course, our
team, as you saw it,
is actually shipping
features as we talk here.
So you'll start seeing
links show up between logs
to traces and Debugger.
There's already a
bunch of integration
that has happened
where you can access
all this data or these tools
directly from your dashboards,
whether it's your
App Engine dashboard
or whether it's your
Stackdriver dashboard.
Incident management
does integrations
for all these tools within your
incident management systems.
And I can't highlight enough
about the extensibility here.
All these tools are publicly
available with our APIs
as well.
And so that lets you incorporate
it within your own systems
so that you can-- let's
say, if you wanted
to add your own custom spans,
where you wanted to measure
your own custom workflows, and
you wanted to still leverage
all the Trace analytics that
we have, then you can do that.
And of course, the best part
of it is, it's all free.
We're not charging
anything for this.
It's available out of the box.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: But
you know, Sharat,
it's not just about the cost.
It's about the value.
SHARAT SHROFF: You got it.
ERIK MCCLENNEY: Thanks.
SHARAT SHROFF: Thank
you very much, folks.
[APPLAUSE]